This March, Netflix is heating up its line-up
with more original movies and TV shows than
you can shake a Fire Stick at.
"Whoa!"
We're staring down the barrel over 50 new
original releases, including new seasons of
Jessica Jones, Santa Clarita Diet, and A Series
of Unfortunate Events — and that's just
the beginning.
Here's everything to look forward to on Netflix
in March 2018, starting with the Netflix originals.
21 Thunder: Season 1
Netflix is kicking off the month with 21 Thunder,
a dramatic sports series that centered on
a fictional soccer team called the Montreal
Thunder.
From the trailer, it looks like a Friday Night
Lights for the soccer crowd, following the
players and coaches through the drama of their
personal lives both on and off the field.
Queue up Season 1 on March 1st.
Flint Town
The town of Flint, Michigan, made headlines
in 2014 when officials discovered that over
100,000 people had been exposed to contaminated
water.
Now, Netflix is centering a new documentary
series on the controversial burg from a different
angle — Flint Town follows the town's law
enforcement as they deal with crime, violence,
and outrage in the wake of the water crisis.
Tune in for every nail-biting moment on March
2nd.
Girls Incarcerated: Season 1
This new documentary series goes behind bars
in juvenile women's prisons to follow the
day-to-day lives of their young inmates.
"I've been locked up in and out for like,
four years."
"Six months…"
"For a year and three days."
Season 1 of Girls Incarcerated arrives on
March 2nd, so tune in for all the drama the
justice system has to offer.
Ravenous
Also known by its original title of Les Affames,
Ravenous is a Canadian drama about a small
group of survivors in rural Quebec struggling
to survive against a zombie hoard.
Ravenous debuted at the 2017 Toronto International
Film Festival to generous reviews and walked
away with the award for Best Canadian Film.
There's not much more hype we can give it,
so check it out when it hits Netflix on the
second of the month.
The World’s Most Extraordinary Homes: Season
Think you've got a crazy home just because
you spent your life savings on lawn flamingos?
"Well, there's something you don't see every
day."
"I tried to think of the most harmless thing
---- something I loved from my childhood."
Well, think again.
This Netflix rebranding of the BBC Two show
takes a stunning look at some of the most
radical residences on the planet, from architectural
wonders nestled deep in the woods to extravagant
island retreats.
Check out Season 1 on March 5th.
Jessica Jones: Season 2
As one of the original Marvel shows on Netflix,
fans have been waiting for a second season
of Jessica Jones since 2015, only to feel
their souls constrict a little more every
year it didn't happen.
Well, the long, bitter wait is over.
Tune in for more episodes of everyone's favorite
alcoholic superheroine on March 8.
"You drinking to remember or forget?"
"Giving a s--- won't get you a better tip."
Bad Guys: Vile City: Season 1
This South Korean crime thriller is a direct
spinoff of the 2014 award-winning series Bad
Guys, which saw three criminals released from
prison to help track down even worse criminals.
Bad Guys: Vile City follows the same premise
with a new cast, and looks just as riveting
as the original series.
Check it out on March 8th.
Ladies First
If you follow Olympic archery, you'll probably
recognize the name Deepika Kumari, one of
the top female archers in the world.
Ladies First is a new documentary that exposes
Kumari's roots to the streets of India and
traces her hard-fought journey from poverty
to one of the world's most elite athletes.
Tune in for what's bound to be an emotional
journey on March 8th.
Collateral
For high-octane murder mystery thrills, look
no further than Collateral, a limited series
about an assassination on the streets of London
and a police detective who's certain that
there's more to the story than meets the eye.
Starring Mudbound's Carey Mulligan, Collateral
looks like a sleek, thrilling mystery that'll
keep you hooked until the last episode.
Find out when it premieres on March 9th.
Love: Season 3
In this comedy series created by Judd Apatow,
Paul Rust and Gillian Jacobs star as Gus and
Mickey, two twenty-somethings caught up in
a neurotic whirlwind of modern romance.
You can experience all the ups and downs when
Season 3 of Love drops on March 9th.
A.I.C.O.
Incarnation: Season 1
Netflix is rolling out a good half dozen new
anime series in March, and one of the most
exciting looks to be A.I.C.O Incarnation.
This futuristic sci-fi story starts with an
experiment gone wrong that creates an oozing
AI monstrosity called Matter that's threatening
to destroy the city… and maybe the world.
Now, it's up to a bionic 15-year-old girl
named Aico to save everyone.
Strap on your roller skates and mark your
calendar for March 9th.
My Next Guest Needs No Introduction With David
Letterman: Malala Yousafzai
In the previous two installments of David
Letterman's well-received hour-long talk show,
the late-night maven sat down with Barack
Obama and George Clooney.
This month, Letterman is hosting a one-on-one
with Malala Yousafzai, the youngest person
to ever be awarded the Nobel Peace Prize.
Take a look when the newest episode lands
on March 9th.
Nailed It: Season 1
Netflix calls this cooking competition show
"part reality contest, part hot mess," which
doesn't sound like your average cooking show.
"Can't forget the vodka."
The show hand picks a group of terrible bakers
and pits them against each other in a culinary
cook-off for a $10,000 grand prize.
Tune in for all the mayhem on March 9th.
The Outsider
Starring Jared Leto as a soldier forced to
begin working for the yakuza in exchange for
his freedom, The Outsider definitely looks
like an epic story with some seriously brutal
action sequences.
Look for it on March 9th.
Terrace House: Opening New Doors: Part 1
The premise of this Japanese language reality
series is instantly familiar — a group of
young people live in a house filled with cameras.
But rather than the fights and drama of similar
shows like The Real World or Big Brother,
there isn't a lot that happens in Terrace
House.
It's just six people being pretty nice to
each other.
For 30 minutes at a time, you can watch a
group of people sitting around watching TV,
eating, and awkwardly making eye contact.
Where will Terrace House: Opening New Doors
take us?
The suspense is gently, apologetically killing
us, but we'll all just have to wait until
March 13th to find out.
Tabula Rasa: Season 1
This series centers on a woman with total
amnesia who finds out that she's the prime
suspect in a murder investigation.
To convince the police that she had nothing
to do with the murder, she has to dig into
her subconscious to prove that she's innocent.
It looks like a trippy, psychological ride,
so don't miss it when Season 1 premieres on
March 15th.
Take Your Pills
Can one drug define a generation?
That's the question asked by Take Your Pills.
Directed by Alison Klayman, this documentary
looks at the excessive use of stimulants like
Ritalin and Adderall in schools and workplaces.
Queue it up on March 16th.
Wild Wild Country
In 1981, an Indian guru began building a city
in Oregon, planning to turn the fringe community
into a desert utopia.
The group was later found to be behind the
largest bioterrorist attack in US history
and a plot to assassinate a government official.
Wild Wild Country is an unforgettable journey
through the group's formation and their later
downfall.
Look for it on Netflix on March 16th.
On My Block: Season 1
In urban L.A., four teenagers struggle to
fit in at their new high school while dealing
with life in the inner city.
That's the premise for On My Block, a new
comedy from the creator of MTV's Awkward.
The first season arrives on March 16th.
Edha: Season 1
There's a lot going on in the trailers for
Edha, an Argentinian series focused on the
dark side of the Buenos Aires fashion industry,
but the main takeaway is that this is shaping
up to be a gritty, brutal show.
In a world of greed and betrayal, who can
you really trust?
Find out on March 16th.
The Legacy of a Whitetail Deer Hunter
Plot details about The Legacy of a Whitetail
Deer Hunter have been few and far between,
but all we need to know is that it stars Danny
McBride and Josh Brolin, and it was produced
by the folks behind Eastbound & Down.
Should be an interesting ride.
The movie is scheduled to premiere at the
2018 SXSW Film Festival before its March 16th
launch on Netflix.
Layla M.
Politically charged and culturally relevant,
Layla M. is a story about an 18-year-old Muslim
girl living in Amsterdam who's dealt with
discrimination her whole life.
But when she marries a man with ties to a
Middle Eastern Islamic cell, her whole world
changes.
Tune in for the riveting journey on March
23rd.
Requiem: Season 1
Originally aired on BBC One, Requiem is a
fantasy thriller about a young woman who heads
out to a small village in the country to find
answers about her past.
There, she discovers a supernatural force
that may threaten everything she's ever known.
Take a look when Season 1 hits Netflix on
March 23rd.
Roxanne Roxanne
Written and directed by Michael Larnell, this
Netflix original movie tells the true story
of Roxanne Shante, a female rapper who became
a legend of hip hop in the mid '80s.
Roxanne Roxanne follows the teenage MC through
her early years and chronicles her rise to
fame.
Get with the beat on March 23rd.
Game Over, Man!
From the team behind Workaholics comes one
of the most anticipated Netflix films of early
2018 — Game Over, Man!
The Workaholics crew star as three slacker
waiters who have to rise to the challenge
when the hotel where they work is taken over
by terrorists.
Tune in for the laughs on March 23rd.
Santa Clarita Diet: Season 2
This zombie comedy starring Drew Barrymore
and Timothy Olyphant received rave reviews
over the course of its first season, leaving
fans clamoring for a second almost from the
beginning.
It may have taken a year, but their wishes
have finally been answered.
Look for it on March 23rd.
The Mechanism: Season 1
Loosely based on a real-life corporate scandal,
The Mechanism is a scripted drama series that
looks into corruption and greed.
With Narcos executive producer Jose Padilha
as showrunner, you know it's going to be a
crazy ride.
Take a look on March 23rd.
Lemony Snicket's A Series of Unfortunate Events:
Season 2
Winding down the month, Netflix is rolling
out the second season of A Series of Unfortunate
Events, with the events of books five through
nine as the main focus of the upcoming season.
If you can't get enough of Count Olaf and
the Baudelaire orphans, mark your calendar.
"Premiering March 30th.
Cheers!"
Rapture
Netflix is doubling down on their hip hop
history with Rapture, an eight-part documentary
series that takes a magnifying glass to the
biggest rap stars on the planet.
If you've ever wondered what goes on in the
personal lives of celebs like 2 Chainz, G-Eazy,
and A Boogie wit da Hoodie, you'll finally
get your chance to find out on March 30th.
First Match
Continuing their theme of female empowerment
in honor of International Women's Day, Netflix
is releasing this hard-hitting drama about
a teenage girl who joins an all-boys wrestling
team.
The movie is based on a short film of the
same name that won some awards in 2000.
Look for it on March 30th.
Happy Anniversary
In this indie comedy, a young couple take
a hard look at their marriage and try to decide
whether they want to get a divorce on their
three year anniversary.
"Happy anniversary."
"Yeah!"
Happy Anniversary stars Ben Schwartz and Noel
Wells, and premieres on March 30.
The Titan
Netflix hasn't promoted this upcoming sci-fi
thriller, but one of the film's writers confirmed
on Twitter that The Titan will indeed be released
as a Netflix original.
Sam Worthington stars as a soldier who gets
genetically altered to survive on Saturn's
moon Titan.
Mark your calendar - The Titan shows up on
March 30th.
Trailer Park Boys: Season 12
Canada's trailer park heroes are back for
yet another season of their award-winning
comedy series.
Season 12 will see Julian, Ricky, and Bubbles
doing more things than ever.
"There's two things that dogs don't mix with:
kitties and Bubbles."
Check it out on March 30th.
Trump: An American Dream: Season 1
This month, Netflix is pointing their political
spotlight on the White House with Trump: An
American Dream, a Netflix rebranding of the
UK-produced documentary about Donald Trump.
The series will dig through over five decades
of the current POTUS' past.
Season 1 drops on March 30th.
Original stand-up comedy
Keep your eyes peeled for a host of brand
new stand-up comedy specials this March, with
a heavy focus on international acts.
Look for a new special by Adel Karam on March
1st, followed by Malena Pichot and Natalia
Valdebenito on the 2nd.
As the month rolls on, Netflix will drop Gad
Elmaleh: American Dream on the 6th, Ricky
Gervais: Humanity on the 13th, and Season
2 of The Standups on March 20th.
If you're looking for laughs, you're definitely
in the right place.
That covers all the Netflix originals.
Now, let's look at all the other movies and
TV shows coming to Netflix in March 2018.
New movies
Netflix is only bringing in a handful of new
action movies this month.
For sword-and-sandals epics, we've got 300
arriving on the 1st and 2017's Troy: The Odyssey
coming on the 12th.
On the sci-fi spectrum, look for 2307: Winter's
Dream on the 1st, along with Battle Drone
and I Am Number Four.
In the mood for lighter fare?
Netflix is adding a great selection of comedies
in March.
The first of the month will see Ghostbusters
1 and 2, Beerfest, and The Bucket List hitting
the streaming service.
Also keep an eye out for Jackass: Number Two
and Jackass 3.5 on the 1st and 15th respectively.
There won't be a whole lot of change on the
documentary front this month, but the few
films that are arriving will definitely be
worth watching.
Look for Expedition China on the 4th, Conor
McGregor: Notorious on the 21st, and Red Trees
on the 24th.
And if that's not enough drama, Martin Scorsese's
Casino is joining the Netflix ranks on the
first, along with Gridiron Gang, Moon, Revolutionary
Road, and Up in the Air.
Go ahead and take our money now.
"Here, take mine too."
New family arrivals on the first of the month
include the animated adventure comedy Alpha
and Omega and Stuart Little 3: Call of the
Wild.
On the 6th, relive the classics with 1974's
Benji and the 1977 sequel, For the Love of
Benji — just in time for Netflix's original
Benji reboot on March 16th.
Finally, Netflix's new thriller lineup is
heating up along with the weather.
All three Cruel Intentions films arrive on
the first, side-by-side with Hostage, The
Descent, and The Gift.
Finally, Let Me In is showing up to creep
out audiences at the end of the month.
Look for that on the 31st.
New television
March won't herald the arrival of much new
television, with only five non-Netflix shows
landing throughout the month.
On March 1st, look for the 18th season of
Law & Order: SVU, followed by the second season
of The Hollywood Masters on March 15th.
Finally, the month ends with the 2018 season
of Men on a Mission on March 27th and the
kids' series Miraculous: Tales of Ladybug
& Cat Noir on the 30th.
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!